the winners and new champions of
dancing with the stars
are
oh my god
iman and daniella
she's paralyzed from the wind this is
crazy why can't you feel your body
because you just won dancing with the
stars
but it took a taxi
attacking a couple of routines to get us
here so
danny needs to recover now
i need to sleep we're in recovery mode
feels like you can hold that thing up
him on you just won yes
big guys though you know uh
thank you guys
okay
just
never thought i'd be having a ballroom
trophy
i keep thinking about that night when
you guys had that incredible freestyle
and you got your first perfect score
they're taking down the set okay it's
over it's
when you all had that first perfect
score and you were like i can't believe
i got tens and now you won the whole
thing
how does that feel have you processed it
um
i think it's just you know
hats off to the work that we put in i
think me and danny set our mind to that
when we got that 40 that
we don't want it to just drop off now
and just you know steam out of the
competition
i think we just put in a lot of hours
and
when it was time to perform it got easy
so
it was fun man we spend the whole time
talking and laughing while we're doing
the routines okay that freestyle tonight
i was watching you going when are they
breathing that was so fast and julianne
huff said it was the best freestyle she
had ever seen in the history of the show
that's incredible we had an amazing
choreographer come out here and help us
with their footwork flew all the way out
flew all the way from chicago to
teachers chicago footwork and it was as
authentic as possible we had the best
dancers in our number they all killed it
with the footwork chicago flew out man
we just we all worked as a team to
create this number for iman and i'm just
so happy the way it turned out okay iman
what do mama and baby girl think of this
uh i haven't talked to him yet i know my
mom probably gonna be choked up she
wasn't able to come today my father
tested positive for kofi oh no i hope he
says okay he okay okay he fight he's
strong he okay uh but my mom wasn't
allowed to come in the building but
uh i can't wait to to put this in our
hands so she could get a chance to enjoy
this because uh it's a tremendous honor
to be a part of such a brand
how emotional is this for you
considering how proud your parents are
and all you've done it's crazy we was
talking about this before i've never
really
only a few times have i gone into
championship games without them being
there and it's like ironically
i won
the other one and it was it was good
uh
so before i told danny i said man i
don't know if it means we lose or win
but i
i won the last time my pop wasn't there
i won the championship okay he's the
sign maybe maybe first ever basketball
player to win first ever win for you how
do setting those records feel they feel
amazing man i
like i said i couldn't be happier i
couldn't ask for more support yeah
danny you looked emotional up there oh i
could i felt like a baby crying
honestly because
i couldn't think of anyone like more
deserving for it because it's never too
late to start dancing no matter what age
no matter what background and did you
lift her up on your head at one point
yeah
yeah unusual danny mom
yeah you put her on your head yeah and i
let go of my hands yeah
[Music]
you